als die tour am 18 märz 2020 wir
begrüßen die die hier sind und natürlich
auch diejenigen die uns über handy oder
telefon oder andere rechner zu schauen
heute ist wieder professor wiler
präsident des robert koch-instituts er
ansprechpartner beim ablauf gibt es eine
kleine änderung nach den statements sind
natürlich wieder ihre fragen möglich
aber das sammel statement ist heute und
wahrscheinlich auch zukünftig dann nicht
mehr möglich
er will ja guten morgen zusammen
guten morgen hier im hörsaal als auch
draußen die zuhörer
ich werde die zahlen etwas langsamer
verlesen damit unsere sprachen dolmetsch
gebärdendolmetscherin frau zwiener einen
leichteren job hat zunächst wie immer
die lage weltweit haben wir mit stand
gestern entschuldigen doch stand gestern
15 uhr 181 1408 fälle in europa sind es
64 1212 fälle in italien 27 1980 fälle
und in deutschland haben wir nun 7156
fälle auf der seite okay gut die tabelle
ist eine veraltete tabelle gewesen
bezüglich auf deutschland wir haben den
aktuellen stand und den aktuellen stand
werden wir immer ab jetzt um 0 uhr
aktualisieren und der aktuelle stand 0
uhr in deutschland am 18
dritten also heute mitternacht heute
also vor 10 stunden 8198 fälle wurden
elektronisch übermittelt an das robert
koch institut
das entspricht einer zunahme von 1.042
übermittelten fällen zum vortag
die gesamtzahl der elektronisch
übermittelten todesfälle bis zum 18 22
00 uhr beträgt 12 das ist gegenüber
gestern keine zunahme die gesamt
incidents in deutschland beträgt
momentan 99 pro 100.000 also wir haben
ein exponentielles wachstum um das klar
zu machen wir sind am anfang einer
epidemie die noch viele wochen und
monate in unserem land unterwegs sein
wird was wichtig ist dass die epidemie
in verschiedenen teilen deutschlands
unterschiedlich stark unterwegs ist wir
haben zum beispiel hamburg aktuell 19
vier fälle pro 100.000 einwohner und
thüringen 35 fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
kurz was uns zu den übermittelten fällen
an klinischen informationen vorliegt für
5700 88 fälle liegen und solche
informationen vor
die häufigsten symptome sind hus bei
rund 55 prozent der erkrankten fieber
bei rund 39 prozent der erkrankten
schnupfen 28 prozent bei 309 fällen
wurde angegeben dass sie keine für komik
19 bedeutsam symptome aufwiesen
ich habe im prinzip heute keine weiteren
zusätzlichen informationen für sie ich
möchte allerdings etwas die zeit nutzen
um eine klarstellung herbeizuführen ich
wurde gestern in einigen medien damit
zitiert dass die derzeitigen massiven
einschränkungen bis zu zwei jahre in
kraft bleiben könnten
das war natürlich ein missverständnis
denn was habe ich gestern sagen wollen
pandemien verlaufen immer in wellen das
ist für diese pandemie genauso es könnte
zwei jahre dauern bis ein großteil der
bevölkerung cupid 19 durchgemacht hat
immun ist und die infektion gestoppt ist
das sagen wir bereits seit wochen
pandemien verlaufen in wellen und wir
nehmen in einem zeitraum an der bis zu
zwei jahren dauern können wir werden in
etwa zwei wochen sehen ob die jetzigen
maßnahmen dabei helfen die verbreitung
des virus zu bremsen
es muss uns aber auch allen klar sein
dass uns dass wir uns noch länger
beschäftigen wird und es ist genauso
klar dass die getroffenen maßnahmen
immer wieder überprüft und angepasst
werden müssen
die verbreitung eines pandemischen virus
kann von sehr vielen faktoren abhängen
von denen einige auch noch nicht bekannt
sind beispielsweise ob es einen einfluss
durch das milder werdenden wetter geben
wird es ist aber offensichtlich dass der
jetzige zustand nicht dauerhaft
aufrechterhalten werden kann sondern ein
extremfall darstellt wir implementieren
diese maßnahmen bzw bundesregierung um
die verbreitung rechtzeitig zu bremsen
wie ich ebenfalls mehrfach klargestellt
habe haben wir die situation dass wir
diese epidemie sehr früh erkannten
weshalb wir noch viele maßnahmen
durchführen können und zu diesen
maßnahmen habe ich seit wochen
aufgefordert und ich werde sie gleich
noch mal explizit benennen es gibt
natürlich auch andere maßnahmen wir
werden immer schauen welche massnahmen
angepasst sind
ich will noch einmal zusammenfassen
maßnahmen zur eindämmung sind extrem
wichtig in der jetzigen lage
und sie werden wichtig bleiben aber es
gibt verschiedene abgestufte maßnahmen
und wir müssen von situation zu
situation zu entscheiden und das ist der
grund warum das robert-koch-institut
informationen benötigt um diese
massnahmen adäquat bewerten zu können
noch sehen zu können ob interventionen
erfolgreich waren oder nicht und in dem
fall wenn nicht dann müssen sie
angepassten darum nochmal mein appell an
die entscheidenden leute das sind wir
alle
zunächst mal an die
oberbürgermeisterinnen landrätinnen und
landräte das sind diejenigen die vor ort
entscheiden mit welcher intensität ein
gesundheitsamt einen ausbruch bekämpfen
kann mit welcher intensität kontakt
nachverfolgen durchgeführt werden können
an diese personengruppen stellen sie den
gesundheitsämtern unbürokratisch
personal aus ihren verwaltungen und so
weiter zur verfügung um die arbeit des
gesundheitsamtes zu unterstützen machen
sie alle verfügbaren ressourcen frei für
dieses ziel
der kern der verlangsamung auf die wir
seit wochen hinarbeiten
die verlangsamung der epidemie der kern
ist die kontakt nach verfolgung durch
die gesundheitsämter und die daraus
folgende unterbrechung von
infektionsketten mittels quarantäne
beziehungsweise isolierung von patienten
nehmen sie unbürokratisch hilfe an
an die gruppe der ärztinnen und ärzte im
ambulanten bereich strukturieren sie
ihre praxen um können sie mögliche co
mit 90 patienten von anderen patienten
organisieren sie sich mit ihren nachbarn
praxen an die krankenhäuser
strukturieren sie ihre kliniken so um
dass sie spezielle bereiche für kurve 19
patienten nutzen beziehungsweise
einzelne kliniken ausschließlich als co
at 19 kliniken strukturieren brauchen
sie ihre intensiv und
beratungskapazitäten auf und zwar
verdoppeln sie sie mindestens bauen sie
so hoch aus wie es ihnen möglich ist
universitätskliniken krankenhäuser
sollten unabhängig von
trägerorganisationen
studierende ausbilden ärzte aktivieren
wenn sie auch jetzt im ruhestand gibt um
sie umgehend auszubilden an beatmungs
plätzen
wir müssen die kapazität der beatmungs
plätze in deutschland maximal erhöhen
und an die mitbürgern mitbürger setzen
sie die von der bundesregierung
geforderten maßnahmen uneingeschränkt um
abstand halten mindestens 15 meter wo
immer sie können bitte reduzieren sie
soziale kontakte das virus wird nur von
mensch zu mensch übertragen das muss
ihnen allen klar sein und darum können
wir die vertrag die übertragung
eindämmen
durch dieses verhalten wenn sie symptome
haben wie fieber trockener husten
atemwegsinfektion bitte bleiben sie zu
hause rufen sie ein arzt an und ihre
ärztin und lassen sich bereits sagen was
zu tun ist sie behalten auskunft von
diesen ärztinnen und ärzten
schützen sie und dass der dritte punkt
schützen sie bitte unsere alt und
hochhaltigen mitmenschen sowie unsere
chronisch kranken vor ansteckungen und
das tun sie durch all die maßnahmen die
wir vorgeschlagen haben
ich will das ganz deutlich machen wenn
wir es nicht schaffen das programm was
wir entworfen haben die maßnahmen die
wir empfehlen und die auch die
bundesregierung erlassen hat vor wenigen
tagen
wenn wir es nicht schaffen die kontakt
und in den menschen wirksam und über
einige wochen nachhaltig zu reduzieren
dann ist es möglich dass wir in zwei bis
drei monaten bis zu 10 millionen
infizierte in deutschland haben mit
einer entsprechenden erheblichen
überlastung des gesundheitswesens wir
alle können dazu beitragen dass dieses
zahl szenario nicht wahr wird
aber unsere berechnungen zeigen eben
auch dass es möglich ist die
erkrankungswelle durch die minimierung
der kontakte deutlich zu drücken
die konsequente uns das gelingt desto
besser also nochmals bitte unterstützen
sie die eingeleiteten maßen am halten
sie abstand möglichst mindestens 1,5
meter versammeln sie sich nicht
bleiben sie zu hause wann immer es geht
und vor allem auch wenn sie krank sind
halten sie die hygieneregeln ein die sie
auch alle kennen kümmern sie sich um
ihre nachbarn wenn diese unterstützung
brauchen wir brauchen jetzt vernunft und
solidarität und wenn wir das haben und
das umsetzen dann können wir die
erkrankungszahlen drücken herzlichen
dank deutschland 160000 es vor wochen
durchgeführt werden
haben sie eine gesamtzahl seit ausbruch
dieser krise und zweitens sie werden es
immer wieder gefragt aber ich wollte mal
darauf eingehen warum die fall
sterberate in deutschland so gering
aussieht also die test kapazitäten die
wir vor etwa drei tagen mitgeteilt
bekommen haben sind etwa 160000 und ich
gehe davon aus dass eben auch diese
160000 tests dann auch durchgeführt
werden
ich kann aber noch sagen dass die test
kapazitäten auch noch weiter zu steigern
sind wenn man unbürokratisch noch zb den
bereich der tiermedizin nutzt es gibt in
der tiermedizin in den gesundheitsämtern
teilweise große test kapazitäten
weltweit ja teilweise große ausbrüche
waren ich erinnere sie zum beispiel an
die blauzungenkrankheit wo er
hunderttausende von tieren getestet
wurden und das ist die selbe testmethode
das heißt also wir können die test
kapazitäten weiter erhöhen
zweitens zu ihrer frage mit den
todesraten auch hier nochmal ganz klar
wir stehen am anfang dieser epidemie
wir sind einfach nur ein bis zwei wochen
vor italien um hier ein beispiel zu
sagen das heißt also wir haben einen
exponentiellen verlauf der epidemie die
zahlen werden weiter steigen und auch
die zahlen der toten
aber ich will auch noch mal sagen wir
stehen am anfang und darum können wir
jedoch die ganzen maßnahmen die wir die
ganze zeit fordern die können wir
umsetzen
das heißt wir können dafür sorgen dass
wir noch mehr menschen schwer kranke
menschen versorgen könnten in kliniken
und ich möchte auch noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen dass eben vier von fünf
infizierten ja nur leichte symptome
haben das heißt also schon sehr sehr
viele menschen gesundet sind und diese
menschen sind immun und können dann
weiterhin ein sorgen loses leben haben
das heißt also es wird sehr sehr viele
menschen gäben diese krankheit
überstehen aber wir müssen durch die
erhöhung der kapazität im
gesundheitswesen und durch die kontakt
reduktion die anzahl derjenigen die
schwer krank werden auf ein minimum
reduzieren
ja ich habe alle alles was bürokratisch
machbar ist muss getan werden das ist
unsere meinung das ist die meinung von
jedermann und jeder wird genauso
glücklich sein wie ich wenn es den
impfstoff früher gibt
ich hoffe darauf ich persönlich schätze
ist realistisch ein dass es im frühjahr
20 21 sein wird ich hab' ich freue mich
wenn ich mich täusche und es früher sein
wird wir müssen ja einen
sicherheitsprofil haben ja also wir
müssen ein sicherheitsprofil haben auch
impfstoffe können nebenwirkungen haben
aber es werden an allen möglichen
konzepten gearbeitet das können sie
glauben sowohl auf ebene der whu als
auch auf zulassungs ebenen der eu
fd deutschland das ist also sie können
davon ausgehen dass alles was möglich
ist ohne aber die gesundheit von
menschen zu gefährden getan wird
das ist eine erfahrung die wir gar nicht
so selten haben bei viralen infektion im
mund und rachenbereich ob das spezifisch
ist oder besonders häufig ist einfach
bei corona virusinfektionen wissen wir
noch nicht es gibt erste hinweise dazu
dass es ein forschungsgebiet an dem wir
natürlich auch arbeiten
naja dieser könnte sein müssen wir erst
mal untersuchen werden wir sehen ob das
so ist wenn es so wäre wäre es gut
sie sagten gestern die bürger sollen
sich die hände war schon intensiv so oft
sie können in ihren eigenen empfehlungen
auf der webseite des
robert-koch-instituts die sogenannten
krinke empfehlungen zur in der
infektionsprävention schreiben sie genau
das gegenteil dort schreiben sie
händewaschen sind auf ein notwendiges
minimum zu reduzieren und stattdessen
die hände zu desinfizieren weil die
hände waschen
die mikroorganismen nicht auch ein
unkritisches niveau reduzieren können
dass ihre erste frage wie kommt es zu
diesem zu dieser also diesen absoluten
widerspruch
die zweite frage wäre dann können sie
bitte eine literatur stelle angeben aus
der erfolg dass man sich mit
händewaschen derart schützen kann dass
die viren keine ansteckung mehr bedeuten
auf den händen und dann würde ich gern
noch wissen die wer sagt dass die hände
waschen die viren sogar abtöten kann
sind sie auch der meinung also die
literatur stelle können sich ihr nicht
geben habe ich nicht im kopf werden wir
ihn besorgen können zu den king coo
empfehlung das ist ein missverständnis
dass ich gerne aufklären die klinko
empfehlungen sind für ärzte und personal
in krankenhäusern
was sie alle verstehen müssen und das
ist vielleicht auch nicht immer so
einfach
wir reden einmal über den umgang mit
patienten in einem hoch infektiösen
gebiet also
wir sie sind in einem krankenhaus sie
haben zum beispiel nosokomiale infektion
und ist natürlich klar dass sie in
dieser region wo also wirklich eine hohe
last ist von krankheitserregern also im
direkten umfeld von patienten dass sie
dort natürlich deutlich höhere
hygienemaßnahmen fahren als im
häuslichen umfeld
da ist natürlich alles muss alles getan
werden um die viruslast oder
irgendwelche anderen krankheitserreger
massiv zu reduzieren
wir sagen dass aber auch im häuslichen
umfeld wenn ein patient behandelt wird
sind ja auch zuhause menschen die krank
sind wenig schwer erkrankt sind die zu
hause behandelt werden können auch dann
empfehlen wir natürlich dass auch in
diesem patienten nahen umfeld der
infektions mittel genommen wird aber
wovon wir reden ist der normale umgang
dass menschen dadurch dass sie zum
beispiel niesen oder husten dass sie
bitte in ihre armbeuge niesen oder
husten und nicht in ihre hände weil in
den händen dann natürlich während sein
können und darum geht es diese viren weg
zu waschen
selbstverständlich können sie auch ein
teil der viren mit waschen einfach
abtöten aber wir reden hier über mengen
wir reden hier über absolute zahlen über
quantität quantitäten und qualitäten und
das heißt es geht darum dass sie die
menge dieser infektionserreger so stark
wie möglich verringern
denn etwas ist auch wichtig in der
biologie gibt es nicht dass jan ein
prinzip sondern ist immer eine frage von
menge das heißt es gibt losen von
infektion also das heißt infektions
dosen und sie können durch ein gutes
händewaschen wir sagen etwa 20
millisekunden hände waschen können sie
die dosis von infektionen und die viren
so stark reduzieren dass sie für die
übertragung keine rolle mehr spiele
die deutsche telekom hat daten data
strömen institute verfügen zur verfügung
gestellt
dadurch kann man wohl die ausbreitung
einer epidemie modellieren um das ist
sicherlich von nutzen aber individuelle
daten intellektuelle bewegung werden
nicht weitergegeben aus privat
rechtlichen gründen genau sowas wird
aber in verschiedenen asiatischen
ländern gemacht um stelle zurück zu
verfolgen und kontakt kommt racing zu
betreiben und auch qualität maßnahmen zu
ja
infos wie nützlich ist in diese daten
für sie und diese fahrt wurde schon
wahrscheinlich gestellt habe wer das
nicht wünschenswert die möglichkeit
individuelle fälle laufwege und kontakte
genau zu verfolgen sollten also ich
möchte ihn gern dazu etwas sagen sie sie
haben sie haben verstanden welche daten
das robert koch institut zur verfügung
gestellt wurde sind nämlich aggregiert
anonymisierte daten und keine
individuellen daten
das wurde leider teilweise in der presse
falsch dargestellt warum sind die daten
für uns nützlich
die daten zeigen uns ob insgesamt die
mobilität der bevölkerung nachgelassen
hat das heißt also anhand der daten
können wir feststellen ob die maßnahmen
die wir fordern und die die
bundesregierung fordere ob die maßnahmen
auch eingehalten werden das ist ein
wichtiger wert denn wir müssen ja
beurteilen wenn wir jetzt
infektionszahlen in der zukunft haben
wir wollen ja bruchteilen warum die
infektionszahlen sich reduziert haben
oder erhöht wurden wenn wir sehen dass
die menschen die maßnahmen gar nicht
umsetzen das sehen wir anhand dieser
aggregierten daten dann wissen wir
den grund dafür dass die intervention
die wir wünschen nicht erfolgreich ist
denn wenn die menschen weiterhin sich so
mobil verhalten wie sie es bis vor einer
woche gemacht haben dann wird es schwer
das virus einzudämmen
das heißt also damit können wir wir
brauchen ja immer die müssen immer
überlegen wie wir wollen ja immer
faktenbasiert wollen wir entscheidungen
treffen wollen wir empfehlungen geben
und wenn wir uns nur verlassen darauf
wir haben natürlich lieber
objektivierbare daten dazu und das sind
natürlich tolle ströme wir können dann
ich weiß nicht ob jemand vorgestern im
heute-journal dieses bild gesehen hat wo
diese ganzen punkte sich bewegen wenn
man die punkte verlangsamt dann
verlangen sagt man eben die ausbeutung
der
epidemien das kann mit diesen daten sehr
gutem essen ich denke dass das ich
glaube das kann ich nicht sagen ich
glaube dass wir die immer wieder
bekommen aber wie oft das ist das da bin
ich nicht informiert
also wie kann man sowieso kaufen wir
können sie nur diesmal umsonst ja das
ist eben in der krise macht man eben
dinge möglich die sonst vielleicht nicht
möglich sind
nochmal ganz grundsätzlich zum
sprachgebrauch also wie man zum beispiel
infizierte person bezeichnet die
tagesschau beispielsweise hat vor ein
paar tagen in bezug auf die infizierten
zahlen und italien 25.000 am sonntag
gesagt diese 25.000 sind an kubik 19
erkrankt ist ist sozusagen also ist es
auch geboten das so zu formulieren
das würde auch heißen dass sofort einen
positiven test man gleichzeitig also
automatisch erkrankt ist oder bei sie
formulieren ja meistens es sind fälle
was ist von journalisten die wir jetzt
einerseits informieren wollen
andererseits nicht unnötig panik
verbreiten
was ist da die beste variante die es
gibt ja in jedem land fall definition
und bislang sind fälle in den meisten
ländern nur solche die positiv getestet
wurden und die mehrheit der positiv
getestet worden sind auch krank das
hängt aber davon ab welche in welche
testung strategie man hat wir haben in
deutschland auch schon einige fälle wo
die menschen kaum erkrankt sind aber
positiv sind das hängt von der von der
strategie der testungen ab also sie
dürfen auf jeden fall davon ausgehen
dass jeder der als fall bezeichnet ist
auf jeden fall mit dem virus infiziert
ist die schwere der krankheit hängt vom
jeweiligen land und meldesystem ab und
von der intensität wie getestet wird
mit erkrankungen also stehen unglaublich
viele bürger arztbesuche
krankenhausaufenthalte das muss nicht
sagen also wie gesagt das können ja auch
menschen zu hause ganz leichte symptome
haben einfach schnupfen heiserkeit die
sind aber dann auch mit 19 erkrankt aber
zu hause also die die es gibt ja einen
großen grad an verschiedenen
schweregraden von erkrankungen die
mehrheit vier von fünf rennen nur eine
ganz ganz leichter krank
das sind aber dann trotzdem mit 19 fälle
kontakte mit den nachbarn oder mit einem
kleinen umfeld naja also wie gesagt wir
schauen uns an wie diese maßnahmen
wirken
und ich kann nur alle auffordern dass
sie eben insgesamt zu wenig kontakte wie
möglich haben das ist ja egal ob das
nachbarn sind oder menschen die man
nicht kennt ja es geht darum wenn sich
so ein kontinuum vorstellen von vielen
tausend punkten die durch die gegend
laufen
je weniger die sich treffen desto besser
ist es und und dieses virus infiziert ja
jeden in jeder altersgruppe das habe ich
ja auch oft gesagt das heißt also
prinzipiell auf das notwendigste
reduzieren also dass wir schauen uns an
wie diese maßnahmen wirken
darum brauchen wir zum beispiel dort von
der telekom werden sie denn überhaupt
umgesetzt die maßnahmen und dann muss
man sich wirklich ab und an immer wieder
alle möglichen optionen anschauen
wir können nur wissenschaftliche
informationen geben darum brauchen wir
diese daten und wir werden schauen was
geschieht
die daten wurden ja gestern uns zur
verfügung gestellt tatsächlich
bearbeiten die natürlich andere menschen
und nichtig ich weiß noch nicht
ich kann dazu nichts sagen gute frage
also zunächst mal der grund ist ganz
einfach wir haben eine riesige mobilität
in der jungen gruppe ja bei den jungen
damen ist ja auch eine sehr sinnvolle
maßnahmen das mal clubs und restaurants
schließt um es ganz klar zu sagen ja und
die jungen können die alten auch
anstecken und darum muss man eben auch
sollte man sich möglichst von seinen
großeltern leben fern halten wenn es
irgendwie geht ja natürlich es gibt auch
einzelfälle sap aber auch immer wieder
gesagt klar gibt es auch in allen
altersgruppen können einzelne menschen
sterben
aber die wahrscheinlichkeit dass schwer
erkrankte in großen in chronisch kranken
und beim alten hochhaltigen versterben
ist natürlich deutlich höher
bekannt kommen beobachten sie eine
mehrheit
drei test kapazitäten und die zweite
frage ist es gibt einen landkreis in
süddeutschland der ostalb reißt da gab
es sechs reisebusse die zum skifahren im
spiel waren
und die sind jetzt zurück und das sind
gestern die vordersten anzahl der
infizierten um 50 prozent gestiegen ist
um 85 prozent gestiegen
also nochmal etwas was sehr wichtig ist
dass die tests wirklich zielgerichtet
gestern habe ich im griff strategisch
genutzt also zielgerichtet strategisch
eingesetzt werden
es gibt tatsächlich hier und dort
engpässe aber ich gehe davon aus dass
wir durch erhöhung der kapazitäten dass
das lösen der das geschehen beobachten
wir wir haben ja festgestellt dass
tatsächlich nicht nur aufs spiel sondern
aus anderen skigebieten viele fälle
importiert wurden
und das ist ja auch der grund warum die
entsprechenden reisen eingestellt wurden
und skigebiete geschlossen wurden das
ist ein geschehen das wir natürlich im
auge haben und dass uns auch so gemacht
wir können das noch nicht sagen
wenn ich die zahlen sehe die testung
zahlen da gehe ich davon aus dass sie
dunkel sie von in deutschland nicht so
hoch sind wie in manchen anderen ländern
das werden wir auch erst in einigen
wochen wissen sagen ja wir stehen am
anfang einer epidemie gestern kanzlers
hamburg von der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung die nachricht dass in
richtung wochenende möglicherweise die
schutzausrüstung knapp wird der fonds
ist seit immer versuche überall auf der
welt schutzausrüstung zu tragen was
nicht möglich sei als von der
bundesregierung sei nicht bekommen dann
gibt es wiederum presseberichte die über
frankreich sagen sie hätten so eine
strategische reserve von 160 millionen
atemschutz masken gibt es so eine
strategische reserve für deutschland
vielleicht im rahmen des nationalen
pandemieplanes existiert so eine reserve
es gibt reserven ich kann dir die zahlen
aber nicht sagen aber es ist so dass
weltweit die masken knapp werden dass
die schutzgüter einfach nicht mehr
verfügbar sind ich kann ihnen einfach
nur mitteilen dass alles getan wird zum
masken und schutzkleidung zu besorgen
zum anderen auch immer mehr alternative
ideen entwickelt werden zum beispiel
dass man masken aufbereitet wieder
aufbereitet also alles was was machbar
ist um die ressource schutzkleidung zu
erhöhen wird getan und dann muss bitte
ich um verständnis dass christen kürzer
machen müssen und morgen wieder in alter
frische
vielen dank